SMP leader Stephen Flynn
Mr Speaker on Monday as households in
Scotland were Awakening to freezing
temperatures they were met with the news
that the electricity grid had been
upgraded in order to meet the Power
demands of the prime minister's new
swimming pool so may I ask him was it
whilst he was taking a leisurely dip
that he decided to leave households
Downing in their energy bills
[Music]
[Applause]
sister this Mr Speaker thanks to the
actions of this government what we've
provided
it to help families with their energy
bills over the last year and we want to
preempt what the chancer is going to say
later but this is a government that is
committed to continuing to help people
with the cost of living and that's what
you'll hear later on Stephen Flynn
you've got to wonder what planet he's on
Mr Speaker because for households in
Scotland the energy prices haven't been
frozen at two and a half Grand and did
the average bill in Scotland has been
closer to 3 500 pounds and you're
tripling in just under two years but
worse than that the chancellor is about
to get to his feet and announced at the
400 pound energy rebate is about to be
scared for everyone not just in Scotland
but right across these aisles so is it
not the case the notorious aren't
freezing energy bills they're looking to
freeze households
[Applause]
Mr Speaker Mr Speaker actually the
government is delivering for people
across the United Kingdom energy bills
have been our priority which is why over
a thousand pounds of support which is
benefiting households in every part of
our country but he talks about delivery
it's now clear that we know because of
the SMP that the trains don't run on
time the
the police are at breaking point the
police are at breaking point and the NHS
in Scotland experience the longest ever
waiting list Mr Speaker that isn't that
isn't even my assessment that's what we
learned in the smp's leadership debate
last week